Herkese
[Alkış]
merhabalar ben sizden denizi'ni 16
yaşındayım en iyi okullarından bir sınıf
öğrencisiyim yüzmede milli takım dayım
ve şu anki başarılarından ve yüzme
hayatımdan bahsedeceğim size
yüzme benim hayatıma
ailemin benim yüzme öğrenme mi istemesi
Ayrıca bir sporla ilgilenmemi istemesi
ve benim önümde bana örnek olan
kuzenlerime özlemle birlikte hayatıma
girdi
şu an daha beş yaşındaydım 2010 yılında
Ama şu anda hala antrenörüm olan Aybars
hocayla tanıştım
Yüzmeye başladım yüzmede tabi baştaki
resim sadece yüzme öğrenmekte yüzmeye
öğrendim temel eğitimi aldım ve takıma
girdim ana takımın Bu takıma girdikten
sonra başlarda sade 12'ye çapından
sonrasında Türkiye şampiyonalarında
Katılım göstermeye başladım ve bu
yarışlardaki katılımda dereceleri
Mini'yi olması ve yaptığım sonuçların
Türkiye çapında iyi yerlere
gidebileceğimiz göstermesi sonucunda
antrenör ile birlikte kendimize yakın
orta ve uzak olarak hedefler koyduk
yakın hedefler tabi baştan milli takıma
girmek Türkiye şampiyonu olmak ve
sonrasında uluslararası dereceler almak
ve en son kaleme bütün sporcuların
isteyebileceği gibi olimpiyatlara
katılım sergilemek
bunlar için çalışmalara başladık Ben
2014 yılında ilk armasıyla gittiğim
Mersin'de olan Bir yarışmada ilk defa 50
metre sırtüstü ne Türkiye şampiyonluğu
alın benim için gerçekten çok mutluluk
verici de daha 9 10 yaşındayken Türkiye
şampiyonu olmak çok mutluluk verici bir
şeyden E
tabi birşeyler başardıktan sonra
üstüne Kalkmam bir şeylerin üstüne
gitmen gerekiyor antrenörü birlikte
antrenman sayılarında ve antrenman
programlarında düzenlemeler yaptık
antrenman sayılarının arttığı antrenman
yorgunluklarım değişti antrenmanın
içinde yaptığım setler zorlaştı ve bir
sürü değişiklikler yaptık şu ki 2017
yılında Makedonya'da bir federasyon
kalması yaşına gittim ve bu yarışmada
200 metre sırt üstünde derece aldım
tabii böyle dereceler alınca insanın
kendine olan özgüveni artıyor ve bir
şeyler başardıkça daha çok insanın çok
daha iyisini yapısı geliyor
Böylece antrenmanların tekrardan
yoğunlaşmaya devam etti 2018 yılında
okullar arası bir müsabakada Ben kendim
için en iyisini yaparak hattı ve Türkiye
rekoru kırdım en başta 200 metre
sırtüstü da arkasından yüzmede sırt
üstünden ve bu rekorları kırdıktan Sonra
dedim ki kendime Eğer dedim Sen Türkiye
rekoru kurabiliyorsan Demek ki bu şu an
yüzebilen en iyi derece senden ve daha
iyisini yaparsan yine en iyi olabilirsin
kendime bir şekilde motive etmeye
çalıştım
2018'in sonlarına doğru kısmına yarılıp
da bir yarışma düzenlendi Türkiye'de bu
yarışmada baraj geçme nisanda bir
multinations Yıldızlar yarışı olacaktı
ve ben bunun için baraj geçmem
gerekiyordu bu Barajı geçtimi
2018'in sonunda 2019'un başlarında tabi
yurt dışına gideceğim için
kamplara katıldım milli takım kamplarına
arkasından nisan ayında Avusturya'da
düzenlenen multinations Yıldızlar yaşına
katıldım bu mutlu eşiniz Yıldızlar
yaşında
Ve elimden gelenin en iyisini yaptım 100
ve 200 metre sırt üstünde bir oldum ve
şampiyona rekoru kırdım Hem bu yarışın
ardından Türkiye'ye döner dönmez
Edirne'de bir yarış düzenlendi bu
Edirne'ye dişi benim hayatımın dönüm
noktası yani Yüzme hayatımın dönüm
noktası olarak adlandırdığım Yaşasın dan
Çünkü bu Edirne'ye dışında ben
bulunduğumuz sezonun sonunda olacak
yazında olacak Avrupa gençlere of ve
Dünya Gençler gibi çok fazla ülkeleri
çok fazla ülkenin katılacağı çok büyük
bir müsabakaya katılma hakkı kazandım
yüzlüm derece elem ve ayrıca tabi 2020
yılında olacak Tokyo olimpiyatları için
olimpiyat barajını geçtim
başta Avrupa şampiyonasına gitti Morpa
gençler şampiyonasına Tabii musun içinse
gitmiştim ama multinations Alpha
Şampiyonası kadar büyük bir iş değil
Avrupa şampiyonu gittim dünya çapında
kendi ben bunu gördüm hepsini eşit
eğitimi benden birkaç yaş büyüklerin
fazla da ama kendime çok Fazla yüklendim
çok stres yaptım çok heyecanlandım O
yüzden beklediğim Beklediğiniz
performansı göstermedim yani göster
sevdim fayda farklı olur muydu
bilmiyorum
arkasından yaklaşık bir 20 gün sonra
Azerbaycan'da evof orta gençlik
Olimpiyatları Ya müsabakası düzenlendi
bu yarışmada Tabi daha öncesinde
yurtdışı tecrübelerim olduğu için biraz
daha rahat biraz daha kendime güvenerek
gittim bu Of'ta 206 sırt üstünde kendi
Türkiye rekorunu kırdım ve üçüncü kaldım
tabi
üçüncülük aldım Türkiye rekoru kırdım
kendime iyice özgüvenim arttı çok daha
fazla şeyler istedim arkasından hemen bu
heyecanla bu şeyle dünya şampiyonası
gittim Dünya Gençler şampiyonasına Dünya
Gençler Şampiyonası'nda eli o kendi
yaptığım w2019 sezonu kapattım 2019
sezonu bittikten sonra
bir sezon tatil oldu bu sezon tatilinde
de kendime vakit ayırdım dinlendim
vesaire vesaire gezdin tozdun eğlendim
2019 sezon tatilinden sonra
antrenmanlara başladım antrenmanlara
başladım iki üç ay geçti ve malum 2020
yılı Palmiye girdik pandemi Benim için
hatta çok kişi kişi için çok zorlu bir
dönem oldu benim için şöyle etkiledi
beni ben fiziksel olarak ve Mental
açıdan çok fazla etkilendiği pembeden
fiziksel olarak kilo artışı olduğu
meteor olarak yüzmedim için
antrenmanlara gidemediğim için
kapanmadan dolayı bir daha yüz
demeyeceğim Bir daha aynı şeyleri
başarılara imza atmayacağım için
korkmaya Baş şu an tedirgin oldum Tabii
bu Herkesin korkutur Çünkü bir şeyler
yapıyorsun ama yapıyorsun sonra uzun bir
süre antrenmansız kalıyorsun onun
antrenörü ile birlikte online da uzun
uygulaması üstünden online Car
antremanları yapmaya başladık Tabi bu
online Car antremanları bizim yüzme
antrenman larımız kadar bizim vücudumuz
için etkili olmadı ama yinede bir derece
Daha kendimize solmamaya
aradım Mental açıdan kendime gelmek için
çok uğraştım antrenörüm L çok uzun
sohbetlerde bulundum sürekli antrenörü
iletişim halinde kaldım benim beni
rahatlatan
insanlarla iletişimde kalmaya çalıştım
ve pendim dönüş dönemin Efendimiz
sürecine Ben bu şekilde atlattım
pandomim süreci bitti bizim antrenman
larımız tekrardan başladı kaldığı yerden
Bu bir ayak antrenman yaptım ve
arkasından bir onu sakatlık yaşadım Tabi
bu mu sakatlığı da böyle böyle kolay bir
omuz sakatlığı değilde uzun bir süre
antrenmansız kalmama tekrar bu da sebep
oldu 7 aya yakın bir süre Ben antrenman
yapamadım kolumu bu kadar bile
kaldıramıyorum Çünkü canım çok yanıyordu
kolumu kaldıramıyorum Yüzemem
yüzemiyorum Sadece ayak yapmaya başladım
En azından kol kullanmasam da bacaklarım
kuvvetlensin bacakların güçlü kalsın
diye
sonrasında 2020'nin sonunda iş Ben
sakatken tekrar 1 yarışı düzenlendi
Bu yarışta da
yapabileceğimizi Tabi en iyisine şey
yapmamız gerekiyor göstermemiz gerekiyor
çünkü sezonun son yarışı 2020 yılı
bitiyor Tabi ben antrenmansız kalmanın
verdiği etki ve başka sebeplerden dolayı
bu yarışı çok da düzgün geçiremedim bu
ve bu şeyle çok gördüm yaptıklarını
kaçırdın Tabi beni yıprattı Çok üzüldüm
Çok ağladım evde de ama yine de kendimi
bırakmadım pes etmedim 2021 sezonunda
yine de kendi kendim için güzel yarışlar
geçirdim Avrupa büyükler şampiyonasına
katıldım Belki de iki üç yıl önce
televizyondan izlediğini insanların
yanında olmak onlarla birlikte
iletişimde olmak onlarla birlikte
yarışmaya katılmak aynı havuzu paylaşmak
benim için gerçekten Hayatın en güzel
tecrübesiyle Çünkü ilk defa gördüm
insanlar dünyanın en iyi sporcuları ile
birlikteydim bu yarışmada 100 metre
statüsünde tükendi Türkiye rekorunu
tekrardan kırdım Ve arkasından bir
Avrupa Şampiyonası düzenlendi Avrupa
Gençler bu Avrupa Gençler
Şampiyonası'nda da Avrupa V elime aldım
ve Türkiye rekoru kırdım şu ana kadar
bir kaşık 30 tane Türkiye'de korum var
ve ulusal uluslararası arenada birçok
derecem var
şu anda
antrenörüne birlikte kendime hedefler
belirledim şu an sabah-akşam en
antrenman yapıyorum
tabi yakın hedeflerim 2022 yılında
gideceğim İslam oyunları Akdeniz
Oyunları Avrupa gençler Dünya Gençler
gibi büyük yarışlar bu yarışlarda
kendimi kanıtlamak istiyorum Onun
dışından tabii ki En çok istediğim şey
de Paris 2024 Olimpiyatları Paris 2024
Olimpiyatları içinde hedeflerini şöyle
söyleyeyim Paris 2024 Olimpiyatları'na
Evet a Barajı geçersem gidebiliyorum Ama
benim istediğim
sadece olimpiyat barajını geçip oraya
gitmek değil orada elimden gelen tabii
ki En iyisini yapacağım Ama yaptığımda
yarı final belki final bu final görmek
gerçekten Türk yüzmesi açısından çok
önemli çünkü daha önce Türk yüzmesinin
de final Görende sporcu Yok daha
ve
2024'te Umarım bunu ben başarmak
istiyorum
Onun dışında konuşma şuradan devam
edebilirim
Ben
başarılarının Sırrı şu gerçekten çok
çalıştım ama isteyerek ve severek yapmak
gerekiyor yaptığınız işi severek ve
isteyerek yapmanız gerekiyor
antrenmanlarını za isteyerek gitmeniz
gerekiyor antrenmanlarınızı en iyi
antrenmanlarda en iyisini yapmak için
çabalama nız gerekiyor Ben
şu çok fazla antrenman yapıyorum Çünkü
antrenmansız gerçekten olmuyor yani
başarının en büyük sırrı çalışma Tabii
başarının en büyük sırrı çalışma ama bir
anlamda kafa olarak geldi Mental açıdan
kendinizi hazır hissetme
o zaman yapıyorsunuz antrenman yaptıktan
sonra da kendinizi yarışa gerçekten
hazırlamamız gerekiyor Bunun için ben
destek alıyorum mesela
yarışa antrenmanlara antrenörüne onu ok
ısmarla diyorum onun ardından vücudumu
hazır olması için belirli diyet
programları var yani beslenmem problemli
ve programlı Onun dışında kendimi kötü
hissettiğimde psikolog desteği alıyorum
sporcu psikoloji ile görüşüyorum Çünkü
her açıdan yarışmaya hazır olmam
gerekiyor ve ona ancak o zaman iyisini
yapabiliyorum
çok çalışmanız Çok emek harcamanız çok
istemeniz gerekiyor Bazı şeylerin
başarının gelmesi için
şu ana kadar yaptığım her şeyden yola
çıkarak söyleyebilirim ki
başarı için sağlık sağlık içinde spor
güzel günlerde kalın
abone ol